hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over the
most recent and honestly some would say
most controversial arc in tokyo avengers
so far to me it has some of the most
heartwarming moments that we've all been
wanting to see since the very early
stages of the anime when initially
reading this arc i actually thought that
the series was coming to an end
everything just felt so happy like it
had finally fallen into place but
obviously i was completely mistaken and
the end of this arc left everyone
completely speechless this is the
bontine arc of tokyo avengers but
quickly before we get into the video if
you are near in here and want to keep up
to date with the latest tokyo avengers
content and just other anime explained
videos in general then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like as it really helps out
with the algorithm and pushes my stuff
to a bunch of new amazing people this
video here is also the last part
currently out on my entire tokyo
avengers story explained i will be
releasing the valhalla and mobius arcs
separately as well if you are interested
in those but they are extremely short so
i'm not too sure when i'll get them out
exactly but they will be out along the
line so if you do want to catch up on
the other previous arcs before this one
though then be sure to go check out all
of the previous art videos that have
been posting individually recently or
just go and check out like the entire
story itself explained which obviously
features everything up to the end of
this video here but anyway enough of
that let's get into the roller coaster
of this amazing but sure arc following
hanagaki's triumph against his enemy
teteki saki and successfully altering
the present to save the lives of his
loved ones takamichi confesses to mikey
about his time travelling abilities and
his mission
mikey believes him and subsequently
summons the members of tomen to announce
its disbandment
through mixed feelings the gang
universally agrees with the decision
later the tobin captains gather for a
time capsule promising to meet again
takamichi meets with hina who blames
herself for causing the death of emma
due to kisaki's obsession takamichi
comforts her and proposes they marry in
12 years to which she accepts much to
naoto's own surprise takamichi returns
to the prison with all his friends
celebrating the wedding of parchin
however absent from all of them is maki
himself
draken and shifuyu state mikey runs a
successful chain of restaurants and was
busy overseas with work takamichi later
visits mitsuya shot who was responsible
for hina's wedding dress hikai and
yuzuha also entered the shop and the
group reminisces
takamichi returns to his normal life
realizing he is now the manager of the
record store and his former boss but
still living in the same old dirty
apartment takamichi watches the news of
the organization bontine and notices the
hanafuda-like tattoo on one of its
members takamichi and hina visits malian
angry's ramen restaurant while talking
takamichi sees the photo of tomen's
disbandment and inquires about mikey but
neither of them know anything as they
haven't met in over 10 years stating
that the only information they have is
from draken as takamichi sees hina's
earrings he suddenly remembers the
tattoo from the bonten member is
incredibly similar to those used by
izana kudokawa having a bad feeling
takamichi storms out of the restaurant
and goes to confront draken over what he
knows from mikey drakken reveals that
both him and shifuyu lied to takameci so
that he could be happy and warns him
against mikey for he has become
unrecognizably evil takamichi meets with
naoto with the letter informing him
about bonten the current worst criminal
organization in japan involved in
gambling fraud prostitution and murder
naoto subsequently informs that bontin's
leader is not izana but his brother
mikey leaving takamichi in shock at the
same time santo who is an executive of
bontin is seen murdering traitors on
mikey's order takamichi is stuck in
disbelief that mikey could have turned
out evil and requests to shake hands
with naoto again nato is reluctant but
eventually concedes however no time
leaping occurs and naoto theorizes that
the trigger for the ability is a strong
desire to change the current time and
naoto no longer feels any desire to do
so since his sister is safe takamichi
later meets with shifuyu and reveals
that he can no longer time leave shifuyu
approves of this for he has achieved his
mission of saving hina takamishi asks if
he knows anything about how mikey turned
evil to what shifuyu responds he tried
to find out but wasn't able to so he
tries to cheer up takamichi by saying
that it is the path that mikey has
chosen and that he is his own wedding to
look forward to overhearing the
conversation kazutura appears and
believes mikey is the same as always but
unable to show his vulnerabilities
because he has taken a path that he
himself did not choose and the two agree
to try and find mikey months later
takamichi has a haircut from akon as
takamichi laments the lack of progress
akuna assures him that him and his
friends are searching but have been
unable for bontine as extremely
dangerous takamichi asks that they stop
instead vowing to find maki himself he
soon gets a call from hakai who proposes
that they open the time capsule these
home and captains meet except for mikey
and the group decides to open the time
capsule reminiscing about the past while
reading their letters draken reveals
that he had mixed feelings about the
disbarment for he never wanted tomen to
end and believes the dismantment hurt
mikey much more but believes that emma
will always be in his heart the group
decides to read mikey's letter which has
him accurately predict everyone's future
occupations and revealing he disbanded
tomen for takamichi's sake and to secure
everyone's future so that they could
learn and prepare for adulthood reading
this the group is put at ease knowing
that they are still connected around the
same time kokucho asks mikey if him not
going to the anniversary was the right
decision to which mikey says it was as
the group leaves takamichi realizes that
they forgot to read his letter to which
he also finds a videotape revealed to
have been put there by mikey with a
message to future takamichi the message
reveals mikey's conflict over his dark
impulses that were kept on check by
shinochiro emma and bhaji and now he's
terrified of what he can become he
wishes takamichi to have a good life and
to not look for him takamichi realizes
mikey's descent to evil is not external
and was caused due to mikey succumbing
to his own darkness kasatur appears with
a lead on mikey but takamichi rejects it
saying it is mikey's wish for him to not
be found takamichi meets with the group
at mitsuya's shop with hina doning the
wedding dress after takamichi goes with
hina and tries on her dress he goes on a
frantic mission to find more information
about mikey's location but is tossed out
from a store as they don't want any
trouble kazutor is concerned about his
sudden rush to find mikey and counters
them to stop engaging on a suicide
mission for he has a wedding in three
days
takamichi finds himself in an abandoned
bowling alley in one of bontin's bases
thinking he cannot meet mikey he
suddenly finds a gun pointed to his head
by sanzu as mikey himself appears in
person maki asks about takamichi's
intentions takamichi replies that he
wants to invite everyone to his wedding
and just like mikey had planned
everyone's futures is the best except
for his
sansu threatens to shoot but mikey has
them retire so they too can talk alone
takamichi asks about maki's dark
impulses believing it was kisaki's
involvement and shinachiro's death that
turned him evil subsequently revealing
he could no longer time leap fahina has
been saved takamichi is grateful to
mikey for securing everyone's future but
now it's his turn to save maiki to which
the latter responds by shooting him from
behind mikey chastises takamichi for
looking for him knowing that it would
end with this result stating his journey
is over admits takamichi's protests that
he will save him mikey reveals he plans
to end everything after this mikey walks
to the roof having visions of shinichiro
emma and bhaji he looks down to people
and imagines tomin gathered there
surprisingly mikey decides to jump to
commit suicide but while falling is
grabbed by immortally wounded takamichi
takamichi implores mikey to save himself
for his little strength left with mikey
protesting about for what he is doing
and that he should let him die takamishi
opposes this decision saying he will do
anything that he can to save him to
which mikey points out that he can no
longer time leap and asks him to put him
at peace takamichi tells him to shut up
and stop burdening himself and to let
himself ask for help even if it's just
once
seeing his determination mikey breaks
down tearfully asking takamichi to save
him in that moment takamichi finds
himself transported to the past once
more to june 06 2008
getting ready for high school sometime
during 2008 hanuma visits kisaki's grave
remembering all the way from his board
days beasting out people to when he
first met kisaki to all of kisaki's
plans up to his death unma mourned him
praising him for not pulling any punches
leaving a beer bottle on his grave he
says that he fulfilled his promise and
declares his intentions to start
something
well that officially brings us to the
end of the currently complete tokyo
avengers arcs be sure to chuck a comment
down below with what your favorite point
and this arc was and even perhaps your
favorite point in the entire series so
far and if you're wondering from what
chapter you need to start at to catch up
on the manga then chapter 206 is the
spot where all you lovely people will
need to start from to catch all the way
back up if you are interested in other
tokyo avengers content or just other
anime explained videos in general then
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough
of that for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in april
bye